il dit aujourd'hui tout juste cent ans
un homme se soulever de terre à bord
d'un engin motorisé à la vapeur les
halls et est inspiré de la chauve-souris
et s'est élevée d'une dizaine de
centimètres sur une distance de 50
mètres un exploit aujourd'hui encore
controversée car clément ader avait le
goût du secret seuls ces deux secondes
vallier espinosa reverrons les halls
quitter le sol de suite la polémique est
née sur la réalité de ce mini vol
pourtant journaux et bill veut
scientifique en ont rendu compte le mot
agression vient de la bouche
ader c'est le premier il est employé
ceux qui adhèrent se proposait c'était
de copier les oiseaux hors aviation sa
plus dire faire l'oiseau jouer l'oiseau
la suite vous dira d'aéroplan
n'est ce pas ils n'ont pas des avions
mais c'est à dire qu'il ya introduit une
bosse on y dit était de conquérir l'air
par le moteur et par un système était
limitée des oiseaux inventeur tous
azimuts clément ader sera aussi à
l'origine du téléphone par exemple
il renouvellera deux fois l'expérience
du 9 octobre 1890 et son troisième
appareil s'appellera l'avion crise il
est sans conteste à l'origine du mot
est-il pour autant le père des avions
ces engins est toujours déséquilibrée
n'ont jamais pu voler les ailes qui
l'utilisaient n'était pas compatible
avec les lys c'est aérostat apparaissent
plus comme les précurseurs des ulm que
des avions que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui